موجز الاخبار من الجزيره اينما كنتم
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
نبدا هذا الموجز بهذا الخبر اذا اصيب
مواطن الفلسطينيون بجروح خطيره وتعرض
العديد لحالات الاختناق كما تم اعتقاله
ثلاثه شبان في بلده قباطيه جنوبيه جنين في
شماليه ضفه الغربيه وذلك خلال عمليه
استهدفت البلده فجر اليوم وافاد مراسلون
ان عشرات الاليات العسكريه توغلت في بلده
قباطيه وحصلت عددا من المنازل واقتحمتها
وعبثت بمقتنايتها وان مواجهات ان مع
المواطنين دارت في بعض المناطق مع قوات
الاحتلال التي اعتدت على المواطنين واطلقت
عليهم قنابل الغاز ولا اعيره المطاطيه
والذخيره الحيه قبل انسحابها
موسيقى فلسطينيه
اندار عليه خلال اقتحامها مخيما الدهيشه
جنوب مدينه بيت لحم صباح اليوم واطلق جنود
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي النار على الاهالي
المحتجين على اقتحام المخيم وفدا شهود
عيان بان قوه عسكريه من جيش الاحتلال
اقتحمت المخيمه وان مواجهات دارك مع
الاهالي
وفي القدس المحتله هدمت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي دون اخطار مسبقا نحو 15 منشات
تجاريه بالقرب من حاجز عسكري في بلده حزمه
شرقيه المدينه
افادتها وسائل الاعلام ان تركيا بتعليق
حركه السفن في مضيق البسفور بسبب جنوح
سفينه شحن قادمه من اوكرانيا باتجاه
اسطنبول واضافت مديريه امن السواحل
التركيه في تغريده على تويتر
بتوجيه فرق الانقاذ والزوارق لسحب سفينه
الشحنه الجانحه في البوصفر
نقلت وكاله برس عن مارك ميلي رئيس هيئه
الاركان الامريكيه المشتركه ان برنامج
جديدا وموسعا لتدريب القوات الاوكرانيه في
المانيا قد بدا امس الاحد بهدف الدفعي
بخمس مئه عسكري
في الاسابيع الخمسه القادمه
قالت وزاره الدفاع البيلاروسيه ان القوات
الروسيه والبلا الروسيه بدات هنا وراه
نجاويه مشتركه الى ذلك اعلنها حاكم مدينه
سيباستيل في شبه جزيره القرم ان منظومات
الدفاع الجوي اسقط الطائره الموسيرتا فوق
البحر الاسود في خليج المدينه وان جميع
الخدمات في المدينه تعمل كالمعتاب على حد
تعبيره ذكرت المصادر المحليه
ايران وسط الصومال تشير الانباء الاوليه
الى مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص واصابه خمسه في
الهجوم هذا ولم تعلن اي جهه بعده
مسئوليتها عن الهجوم كما ان الحكومه لم
تعلق عن الحديث بعد
اين ما كنتم طابت اوقاتكم بكل خير